>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Good
afternoon, everybody.
And welcome to the African
Middle Eastern Division.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb, chief of
the division and I'm delighted
to see you here to attend
this exciting presentation
by Professor Ittai Joseph Tamari,
the director of the Center Archives
for Research on the History
of the Jews in Germany.
Which is in Highland Burg.
A fascinating subject.
The transformation
of the [inaudible]
from manuscript to printed text.
Sorry, I'm paraphrasing, the
title is not quite that way.
This will be followed by very
special display of rare editions
of the Talmud, which your program
says is a unique opportunity
to compare rare editions,
page by page.
I only say a few things about
this division before we start
the program.
Many of you already know
that this division is made
up of three sections.
The African section, which
covers [inaudible] in Africa,
the near East section, which covers
the whole of the Arab world, Turkey,
Iran, Central Asia, the [inaudible]
and smaller areas,
even close to China.
We responsible for 78 different
countries and regions in those areas
and we're very active in collecting,
acquiring, developing collections
in the vesicular, in the
languages of those regions.
We also do briefing for visitors
when they come to the library.
We do symposium, workshops, we
have displays, we have exhibits
and our staff is one of the best
staff you can possibly hope to have.
They're scholars in their own
rights, they know the languages,
they know the culture of
the regions that they cover.
And, so, we serve our
patrons in many ways.
One of which, of course, serve
them with our collections.
But we also bring scholars to the
library as we are doing today.
We bring scholars who can illuminate
and enhance our understanding
of those collections that we
hold and that we treasure.
So, it's so exciting to have
Professor Tamari here with us today.
And to introduce this lecture
is Professor Michael Brenner,
the director of the
Center of Israel Studies
at the American University
in Washington DC.
He's also a professor of
Jewish history and culture
at the Ludwig Maximilian
University of Munich.
So, I think you want
to hear from them now.
And, so, Professor Brenner
if you would please come.
[ Applause ]
>> Michael Brenner: Thank you.
It's a real pleasure to introduce
my dear colleague Dr. Ittai Tamari.
Let me first thank the
Jewish Studies Program
at American University and
also the Judaic Studies Program
at George Washington University and,
of course, the Library of Congress,
who cooperated making this possible.
Especially Ann Brener who
helped us so much here.
I am very happy to see Dr. Tamari
here, who was my colleague in Munich
for many years until he moved
to Heidelberg earlier this year
to direct the center -- to
direct the archives for research
and study of the Jews in Germany.
The major archives for this purpose
in the German speaking world.
He is best known, I think, for his
many publications on Hebrew print.
The history of Hebrew print,
especially in the Ashkenazi world I
would say he is probably the leading
expert in this field today.
Has published many books.
One very beautiful recent book
came out about the Hebrew holdings
of the Bavarian State Library,
one of the leading libraries
actually in this field.
In fact, the only completely extent
medieval Talmud manuscript is
in Munich and many other
manuscripts in early prints.
He has also published numerous
articles on Hebrew printing
and related topics in Hebrew, in
German, in English has been lecturer
in several universities
in Germany and Israel.
Recently gave a lecture series at
the National Library in Jerusalem
and I am really very
happy to see him here.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Tamari, who will speak
about the topic, I think you all
see the front of you on your screen
from manuscript to printed text,
the transformation of the Talmud.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ittai Joseph Tamari:
Thank you very much.
And thank you again for all the
institutions that made it possible
to be here in this
wonderful and amazing place
of where knowledge is
at home, so to say.
What I'm trying to do in the coming
hour or so is to give here in front
of you a kind of introduction
to the theme.
And then I will invite you all
to come with me to the room
in the rare here and see very
fine selection of Talmud volumes
that are presented here, I think.
So, for the first time, one
might say, in such a -- yeah.
Okay, let's start.
The Talmud is considered the corner
stone of the Jewish oral low.
Which is traditionally
comprehended as a compass
that should not be
transferred into written form.
The Talmud is composed of
citations from the mission half,
followed by the Gemara, which
consists of the discussions
of the sages relating at times
loosely to the precursory citation.
But and to what extent
the Talmud was copied
or written down is unknown.
Unfortunately, there are not too
many manuscripts of Talmud treaties
that have survived to our
day, much less manuscripts
that contain the whole copies
of either the Yoma Shimy [assumed
spelling] originated in the land
of Israel, or the Bovini in Babylon.
The persecution of the Talmud
by the church is another cause
for the disappearance of many Talmud
manuscripts and printed versions.
Nevertheless, in the
following minutes I will try
to discuss the transformation
of the text
from its hand written version
to its printed version.
I would also like to follow some
of the prevalent verbal
stereotypes concerning the topic
and compare them with the material
reality of the vast [inaudible]
of literature called the
Talmud, which is the amplest
and the most complicated
Jewish tradition ever created.
The Talmud is also probably
the first multi-layered text
in a tradition that after
the Renaissance and then
in [inaudible] brought
by its printed version,
could no longer be read linearly.
Generally Jewish communities are
considered learned societies,
apart from dealing with
a tradition of learning,
traditions of learning
disputing, ruminating on
and transmitting various
kinds of knowledge,
we may as well turn our attention
to the preparation, production
and dissemination of printed books
through which knowledge
was kept and transferred.
During the first period of
the new technology of printing
with moveable letters that
is in [inaudible] crafted
between about 1415 until
1500, approximately 28,000
to 30,000 titles were printed,
mostly in three European centers,
Italy, Germany and France.
Of those some 140 were
set with Hebrew letters.
Then half a percent of the 140
titles using Hebrew letters,
the biggest section
was biblical text
and their common [inaudible],
something like 38%.
Less than 5% of printed [inaudible]
of this period were Talmud treaties.
But the low percentage of printed
Talmud treaties does not provide
binding evidence of the poor
interest in this kind of literature.
Rather, it speaks to the
practical hardships of printers
in finding appropriate manuscript
copies and matching proper
and suitable commentaries,
as well as the elaborate
and [inaudible] way parts of
text were set on the printed page
or better saying that
they will spread.
We will see all these
later in the rare room.
In 1936 Walter Benjamin wrote
his essay, "The Work of Art
in the Mechanical Reproduction," in
it he argues, among other things,
that through the act of reproduction
the significance is taken
from the original by
taking its context.
The former [inaudible] of the hand
manufactured object gets lost amidst
the multitude of reproductions
and the deliverance
of the reproduced work of art
from its symbiotical
dependence on ritual.
Such are among the most
known citation from his essay
that later had the considerable
influence on the [inaudible].
When considering the printed
Talmud after [inaudible] most
of the arguments Benjamin brought up
tend to show exactly the opposite.
Through the printing of
the Talmud Jewish tradition
and its ritual components
were restructured,
strengthened and standardized.
Learning and ruminating
on its knowledge became
an obligatory activity,
the artisanal quality of the
Talmud manuscripts disappeared,
but the student of the text
became part of a big hard
to quantify society of daily
students of a modern ritual.
Volumes of the printed
Talmud became, if not holy,
at least venerated and took a
central place on the shelves
of the living room of
every learned Jewish adult.
Since the 16th century the Talmud
has possessed, one may say,
a practical [inaudible]
of essentially --
essentiality that was
not feasible before.
In this way two polar
opposites approach each other.
The ruminative individual struggle
with the text approaches
the mass learning of it
in quantities never known before.
Another point of interest that may
strike our attention is the vicinity
of those texts to technology.
From 1520 Venice to our day
with the still new translations
of the whole text now,
the Talmud can be read
on our cellphones and
tablets and so on.
Compared with text
of other religions.
It is most unique.
These and other peculiarities
of the printed Talmud made it
almost form its earliest days along
for goal for printers who were in
many cases during the long history
of printing with Hebrew letters
themselves devote scholars.
Of the some 15 known completed
editions of the Talmud,
as well as numerous partial
publications one can assume a very
active and highly professional field
where they are fascinating efforts
to innovate, improve and squeeze
more content into the limited frames
of the double spread
on both letters.
The texture and the
physical topographical.
Within less than a century the
printed Talmud set a new standards
for the Jewish tradition and
modified it in an essential way.
The study of the Talmud in its
new version, the printed model,
gave almost every interested
person the opportunity
to encounter it independently
and study it without a mediator.
Beyond that, since then, there
has been much easy access
to different bodies of information
that is a [inaudible],
commentaries and so on.
That accompany the Talmud's main
text, making the need to travel
to study with learned devotees or
see scarce manuscripts obsolete
for most readers and users
of the printed Talmud.
Through the act of printing the
main text lost considerable quantity
of entrancing variations.
Subsequently, parts of text that
did not confirm the commentaries
of [inaudible] and the following
[inaudible] were neglected
and eventually vanished.
Further phenomenal losses
of Talmud text were those
of the traditional circulating
in the Iberian Peninsula during the
expulsion of the Jews from Spain
and subsequently Portugal
from 1492 to 1496.
Most of the manuscripts, as well
as printed treaties form these area
and region did not survive.
The [inaudible] tradition
of studying the Talmud,
particularly in its printed version,
came to us in a diminished,
incomplete form.
The first generation of printers
and their printed efforts,
scarcely proceeded
beyond their own lifetime.
Members of the Sandino [assumed
spelling] family succeeded
with a printing during
the 16th century.
Two descendants succeeded
even longer.
But it was a Christian
mention from [inaudible]
that through enormous
investments in money and manpower,
managed to publish in
Venice more than 250 titles
of books printed with
Hebrews letters.
Among others the publications
included the [inaudible] and both
of the Talmud from more
consecutive editions.
To start with a cliché that Talmud
is referred to us as an ocean
because of its monumental
volume and the immense numbers
of themes mentioned and
discussed among other things.
Let us have a look at
the means that grant
that ocean its form
and lay its boundaries.
The text next stage
of our consideration
concerns the outer form
of the double spread of the Talmud.
Okay. This is what
was mentioned before.
This is the famous -- most famous
complete manuscript of the Talmud,
a Babylonian Talmud called, "Cod.
Hebr." 95, which was
written in France, 1342.
In systemizing the whole text,
students of the Talmud could
study the text more easily
and profoundly then they ever
could in its handwritten version.
As long as the Talmud was
handwritten, the different parts
of its contents, the [speaking
foreign language] were not always
set clearly apart.
Nor were there always written
separately from other text,
let alone written on
the same surface.
The fact that those texts were
sometimes interweaved has to do
with those who read or prepared the
manuscripts already being acquainted
with the full length text and
therefore preparing the new version
to function as a commemoration.
Another development one may
find in the later 12th century
in the same three European centers
of printing, was manuscripts
or so called multi-layered books
that gifted craftsmen created
using varying page layouts
in different forms of
diverse text clusters.
Let us have a short look at it.
Here you see a manuscript which
was written in Segovia, Spain,
containing the -- one of
the books of the Bible.
And you can see that the copies
played with various layers of text
of commentaries and so on.
They are not functional,
these layers,
but you can see it
was a known tradition.
Another sample coming from Vienna.
Since the 13th century,
the catholic respondents
in Italy have used a
multi-layered double spread design
for printing the [inaudible]
of the church log.
Here you have one of the famous --
oh, I'm sorry, it's got a bit lower.
It's a very known manuscript
of the catholic law,
which gives you an impression how
catholic law texts were written
down in the 14th century.
A similar multi-layered design of
the printed page was later used
in Spain to print the
complutense polyglot bible.
Here you have it.
It was printed 3 years -- in 3
years and you may see the -- yeah.
Hebrew, Latin, you have it
here, the Aramaic translation.
There was some of the conditions
before the first printed --
these were the conditions
before the printed --
the first printed Talmud treaties.
The first attempts to print
the Talmud treaties tried
to structure the reading surface.
This effort is neither new,
nor appears primarily
in the Jewish tradition.
It is rather one of the intrinsic
qualities of printing text.
The appearance of fully functional
multi-text themes is in Jewish text,
like the Talmud, or the Bible,
the lord is a genuine innovation.
Here one can read the main
text, on the same page,
compare it with other
text in the old tense,
thus commemorating
the oral tradition
in which the Talmud was
brought up and evolved.
The printed Talmud is
a cultural phenomenon,
it's one of the rarest
idiosyncrasies.
Its main textural components
are still unconsolidated,
whereas its format, the layout,
even the exact positioning
of the wording are already fixed.
This is a page of the Sandino
[assumed spelling] it is believed
to be the first dated
treaty of the Talmud,
a treaty [inaudible] was
printed in Sandino 1484
and then again in Bomberg.
And this is our June,
the Bomberg printing.
The Sandino's were the first to
use the known [inaudible] layout
of the double spread, called the
Talmud, but various obstacles,
above all finances, hindered them
from fulfilling their father's wish,
mainly printing the whole Talmud.
The treaty, [inaudible], regarding
the menstruating woman is considered
the first dated Talmud treaties.
It was first printed 1484 in
Sandino and for the second time
and for the second time in 1509 in
[inaudible] served as the prototype
for the later Bomberg Talmud.
Daniel Bomberg a cloth and art
merchant was a religious Calvinist,
who was sent by his
family to Antwerp
to in Antwerp to Venice in 1516.
His friend, the appestat Felix
[inaudible] taught him Hebrew
and advised him to open a
printing shop for books in Hebrew.
Bomberg did not hesitate to invest
immense sums of money and man power,
previously unknown in
the Jewish world and open
in Venice a big printing shop that
functioned as an editorial office
for his future publishing plan.
In this shop he employed dozens
of Jewish scholars from all
over North Africa,
Germany, France and Italy,
who otherwise were not alone
to stay in the lagoon city.
Two or maybe three of them
converted to Christianity.
Nevertheless, after four editions
of the Talmud and more than 20 --
250 titles, he abruptly left
Venice and returned Antwerp,
leaving the printing shop to be
distributed among other printers.
Mark Antonia Degala
[phonetic spelling],
Mark Antonio Justinyani [phonetic
spelling], and [inaudible].
Although, his editions consisted of
presumably 500 to 1500 copies each.
His publishing activities could not
be considered a financial success.
Yet, in the Jewish tradition,
he's praised as a great
minister of the Jews.
Therefore, our family,
this is the copy
that the estate library
in Bavaria has.
It's a complete set and it's
in a very fresh situation.
This is the so called
Gustiononi copy.
And this is [inaudible],
it is the best copy
that was printed in this time.
before our family printers active in
[inaudible] and later in Amsterdam,
Pisa, Venice and Torino,
printed in 1553
in Sabbionetta [assumed
spelling] in an enhanced edition
of the Talmud treaties, which is
called [speaking foreign language]
or marriage ceremony.
Edited by the renown
scholar Joshua [inaudible].
With a Cornelio Adelton [assumed
spelling] that worked before
with Bomberg as the head
of the printing shop.
Unfortunately, no further treaties
of that kind was printed
in Sabbionetta.
Daniel Bomberg significant
achievements is the printing
of the Talmud, which later
became the text [inaudible].
It was produced in four
consecutive editions.
Only the first was complete edition
containing 44 message thought
or treaties.
The other three were as follows.
The second was contained
only 40 treaties.
The third eight.
And the fourth 33.
The wonderful letters in
[inaudible] style were cut
by the famous letter cutter Geome
Lebardafirst [assumed spelling].
Some of his original
punches are kept nowadays
in the Plantin-Moretus
Museum in Antwerp.
The year 1520 when the Bomberg
Talmud was first printed could be
seen as the amoos meelabilous
[phonetic spelling]
for in this year not only the
[speaking foreign language]
of Prague, [speaking
foreign language] was born,
but also this my [inaudible]
Talmud edition made its appearance.
10 years later another important
student of Jewish knowledge was born
in Prague and namely
[speaking foreign language].
Who substituted for
[inaudible] in Prague.
He would later consider the
publishing of the printed Talmud,
[inaudible], which is
called "The Set Table,"
compiled Roberreso Caro
[assumed spelling],
a trend of leaving the old
tradition of learning overly
and studying out of books.
Later he would gain his own renown
and compose his famous [speaking
foreign language] meaning "Garments
of the Kingdom" to assist
those who will still depend
on old Ashkenoshic [assumed
spelling] tradition.
This new way of printing the Talmud
was not accepted without opposition.
Centuries later there are
still printing, Ashkenosic
and Sephotic [assumed
spelling] alike,
who object to the Bomberg layout.
Nevertheless, they will indicate
in their Talmud editions
their parallel passage
in the Bomberg edition, which
has already become the standard.
Over the course of the 17th century,
all the Talmud edition adopted
the Bomberg double spread style
and that was eventually
the multifaceted situation
that was known to be to [inaudible]
scholar [speaking foreign language],
when he prepared the last
monumental Talmud enterprise
in recent centuries.
The Rome, or better
known as [inaudible].
Let us have a few pictures to see.
This is the [inaudible]
edition of the Talmud,
made in Basil by Ambrosio Froben.
But the men behind it, [inaudible]
came from Italy and brought
with him letters and then you
-- and new stanza edition.
This Basil edition, which is
known as the Stanza edition,
was printed many editions
through Europe.
Here we come to the [inaudible]
tradition and you can see
from the outside that
this is another tradition
that we do not know so much.
The letters look much
other than we had before.
And as you can see here in the
[inaudible], these are editions
that were made for
students, young students,
so they can read the main
text in the main column
and older [inaudible],
older commentaries were
set in a shorter form.
This is another version of the
Talmud that was made in Poland.
It used a very small letter in
order to let the original text
of Bomberg inside, but
nevertheless it didn't manage
to have the whole commentaries
behind.
We will see it in the room later.
It's a very moving story about
this Talmud that was printed
in 15 copies, 500 of them were
given to poor students of the Talmud
in order that they could read the
Talmud and study it in their homes
without having to pay for this.
This is another edition for
students, for young students
in order to read the
Talmud in its basic version.
And here we come to the modern
era, where the known letter code,
Amsterdam, makes its
appearance, which --
of which we have to our days.
This is what happened
as the late emperor
of Habsburg didn't let
printed books from other places
in Europe come inside his reign.
Christian printers started to
print the Talmud with letters
that they could buy in
Amsterdam and other places.
One of them was [inaudible].
A very nice example.
And this is the last, as I said
before, the last enterprise
that was done printing
the Talmud Villa,
which is the new Bomber, so to say.
I would like you now to come with
me to the room and have a look
at the volumes that we have.
And, yes.
>>Ann Brener: Okay, on behalf
of the Hebraic Section I'd
like to thank Dr. Tamari
for a wonderful talk.
[ Applause ]
And we do want to invite you back.
I hope everyone has a checklist.
As you will see our display
is divided into five groups.
Each group is open up to the same
page, but in different editions.
Now, usually when we have a
display I'll let you all walk
around in peace and quiet
and enjoy everything.
This time I suggest that we treat
this as a master class and --
because this is such a wonderful
opportunity to have such a scholar,
to walk around with us and to
point out to us the differences
in the different editions.
So, again, warmest thanks to Dr.
Tamari and please use the side doors
and come on into the display room.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.